chris marola any puzzle games in the
past 10 years that you loved
well um so right around the time the
witness came out a couple months later a
game came out called steven sausage roll
which sounds like a very silly name um
it really is one of the best puzzle
games ever made and um
uh
i recommend people play it
i i don't want to spoil anything i can't
tell you why um
you may bounce off it it's pretty hard
um but if you're interested in puzzle
games it's amazing um i got to play it
actually
before
the witness came out because i was
playing a pre-release version and i had
this feeling like wow
this
might be better than the kind of stuff
that i'm doing
that's i mean that's
pretty amazing to see but
also worrisome it's like oh man is this
thing that i'm working on gonna actually
be good
there's some other games
that came out since
since then
i mean i really like those actronics
games which are kind of puzzly they're
kind of a lot about programming
there's one particular game of his
called opus magnum that i think is very
approachable
um
so
you know um
you just said
man i don't know if my game will be any
good now when you say that what are you
referring to as being good is it if
people enjoy them is it if people like
that's an overstatement because
like the feeling was more it's an
oversimplification because i knew it was
good right
um
for my you know again for my metric of
what's good um but
um
there is a certain uh
way
that we went into at length before about
going into a possibility space of a game
of like what how things work and
discovering what can happen
from that and and finding the best
things and giving them to the player
right and
um
i had done a bunch of talks where i
discussed that process but i hadn't
really seen much in the way of other
games that did that and steven sausage
roll actually does that
um
and
it's it's just an amazing game you know
um
very happy that i got to play it so
it does that in a different way i would
say than the witness did and so
it was like wow
somebody else is doing the same kind of
a thing
um
whereas i thought i was sort of the only
person doing it i guess is is the
feeling right so
it's a good feeling because you don't
feel as alone anymore
have you reached out to the developer
oh um i mean he sent me a pre-release
copy so you know he's someone who i've
never met in person but you know knew
about and we'd corresponded and stuff